wasn't that hard we had a script that I
thought was
a good script we had a director that I
admired for a long time it was a
pleasure to be able to come back what
surprised me I'm bothered about that
you're in it so much we don't want to
give too much away but how funny it is
this is great the witch descrip are you
here out here yes trip coming back for
the words the experience was was
wonderful had a wonderful time to be
changing Avram throws a great party
we have fun every day fit more second
time wrap knowing that this isn't this
isn't what every film is like every time
we did it this new part
we've got Daisy Ridley standing behind
John boyega they were fantastic and they
held their own with you and yeah yeah
terrific
I'm the you know I'm really glad for the
casting
for the care that JJ took them crafting
the script to introduce these characters
it's really terrific some of my favorite
moments were when you were on stream
with princess general lair for you were
they the most special was it did with it
with doing every bit of the story
deserves the same attention just as much
fun to do as any other you know it's
it's distill this script doesn't spend a
lot of time dealing with extraneous
matters there's a lot of mister you'd be
brought up to date a lot of important
plot points to be accomplished